معنا من القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان سمري
ورصد لهذه التظاهرات في تل ابيب وفي القدس
وكذلك هذا الجدل في الكنيست بين الحكومه
والمعارضه ومجلس الحرب واعضائه المختلفين
[موسيقى]
نجوان نعم بالفعل هذا الحراك في مدينه
القدس هو جزء من عده مسيرات وتظاهرات
ووقفات احتجاجيه شهدتها مدن عده داخل
اسرائيل هذا اليوم وهي بتفضيل بالاساس من
حراك نسائي وجهات يساريه
يطالبون بالعمل الوي من اجل ابرام صفقه
تباد واعاده الاسرى الاسرائليين المحتجزين
في غزه كافه
يحملونهم ويحملون
ويرفعون تقول لن نتوقع حتى يتم اعاده
الاسرى والرهائن
كافه وكما تسمعون ربما يرددون هتفات تقول
الان الان ونريده احياء وليس في توابيت
كما حدث مع عدد من الاسرد قتلوا في غزه
تحديدا جراء عمليات
ع
الاسي
بادت في مساعيه لاستعادت ضمن العمليات
العسكريه كذلك نرى ايضا
لافتات تقول ان الوقت بدا ينفد مثل هذه
اللافتات التي بداوا يحملونها في الايام
الاخيره الماضيه وتقول الوقت ينفذ لكنها
تحمل ايضا اكثر من معنى باللغه العبريه
هذه ال تقول ايضا الوقت ينف ورحمهم الله
تحمل معنيين وهي تعثر في الحقيقه عن خشيه
العائلات من ان يقطل الاسرى داخل غزه هذا
الحراك زين العابدين هو حراك نسائي
بالاساس وهم يقومون بانهم يستطيعون
التاثير على غرار ما حدث عام 97 عندما
شكلت موعه من الامهات اربع امهات تحديدا
لجنود كانوا في جنوب لبنان وكان ل حراكهم
تاثير كبير على الشارع الاسرائيلي في حينه
وفي نهايه الامر تم الانسحاب من لبنان
بعد الحراك الشعبي الكبير الذي بالاساس
قادته هذه الامهات هنا ايضا لافتات تطالب
بوقف الحرب وهناك ايضا من كان يحمل قبل
قليل رايت ايضا لافتات تتهم الحكومه بانها
لا تفعل كل ما يلزم من اجل استعاده الاسرى
وكانت هناك لافته ايضا ان صوره النصر التي
يبحث عنها مجلس الحرب هي اعاده الاسرء
المحتجزين او تتمثل باعاده المحتجزين اذا
هنا يرددون عشاب عشاب ربما هذه الكلمه هي
الاكثر التي
في هذه المظاهرات وهي تعني كلمه الان الان
باللغه العبريه هناك بطبيعه الحال نوع من
توجيه الاتهامات لمجلس الحرب والحكومه
الاسرائيليه على راسهم بنيامين نتنياهو
وبالاساس الخشيه من انه يحاول طيله الوقت
ارضاء شركائه من الجم المتطرف او الاكثر
تطرفا فيذه الحكومه
بلت وزير الماليه وامار بن كبير الذان لا
يعني ييان بانهم ضد وقف الحرب مقابل
الافراج عن الاسرى واستعاده اسرى محتجزين
لذلك يقولون بان هذه الحكومه لا تفعل كل
ما يلزم وتحديدا مجلس الحرب والكابينه او
المجلس الوزاري
الامني المصغر هذا اليوم سمعنا بيني جانس
الوزير في مجلس الحرب يصرح في كلمه مسجله
بان اعاده المحتجزين اولويه اخلاقيه وواجب
اخلاقي لهذه الحكومه لكنها لا تتناق مع
تحقيق اهداف هذه الحرب من خلال اخضاع حركه
حماس وهنا ربما اراد بيني جان او حاول
اخفاء الخلافات والاختلافات في المواقف
داخل مجلس الحرب التي يقودها
هو او يق هو احد التات التي تال وضع اعاده
المحتجزين عليا في مجلس الحد بينما
يصر نتنياهو ووزير الدفاع ي على ان مزيدا
من العمل العسكري والضغط العسكري على حركه
حماس سيقو في نهايه الامر الى الافراج
عن شكرا جزيلا لك نجوان سمري من
القدس